Luke was eleven when his family moved from the normal, boring suburbs to what amounted to, basically, the coolest place on earth. His dad got this job as the manager of this tourist park called the Butterfly Farm.
卢克十一岁那年，全家从普通乏味的郊区搬到了地球上最酷的地方。他父亲在那儿找到了一份工作，担任一家名为“蝴蝶农场”的旅游公园经理。
--that had domes filled with rainforest and exotic birds and butterflies and a miniature train track and pony rides and mini bike rides and a launching ramp for the water skiers who came and skied--
——那里有布满雨林、珍禽异兽和蝴蝶的圆顶大棚，还有微型火车轨道、骑小马项目、迷你自行车骑行，以及供滑水爱好者使用的发射台——
Also, a spider house, a picnic area, a snake house, and a guy named Vic, who did a show with his collection of deadly snakes. It's This American Life, by the way, from WBEZ Chicago. And the only bad thing about being 11 and living out in the countryside on the grounds of such an incredible place was the school that Luke attended.
此外还有蜘蛛馆、野餐区、蛇馆，以及一个名叫维克的家伙，他会表演展示自己收藏的剧毒蛇。顺便说一下，这是来自WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》。对于一个11岁住在乡下、处在这样一个神奇地方的孩子来说，唯一糟糕的事情就是他上的那所学校。
This was in Australia, outside what was then a little town called Wilberforce. And the other students were these tough kids who didn't accept Luke at all, which is why it was such a great day for Luke when his whole class took a field trip to the Butterfly Farm.
那是澳洲的一所学校，位于当时一个小镇威尔伯福斯外。其他同学都是些不好惹的“混混”，根本不接纳卢克，所以当全班去蝴蝶农场实地考察时，对卢克来说真是太棒的一天了。
It was my place, my kingdom, my turf, and I felt extremely excited and filled with anticipation that I could kind of relax and show off at the same time.
那是我的地盘，我的王国，我的主场。我感到无比兴奋，满怀期待，觉得既能放松心情，又能好好炫耀一番。
Show off, especially because his dad had asked the snake handler, Vic, to come in and do a show for Luke's class. Normally, Vic didn't work during the week. There weren't big enough crowds to justify it. But Luke's dad, knowing this would be good for Luke, asked him to come in special.
之所以能炫耀，特别是因为他爸爸请了捕蛇人维克来为卢克的班级做表演。维克平时周中是不工作的，因为游客不够多。但卢克的爸爸知道这对卢克有好处，特意请他过来。
And that meant that I was going to help Vic. We'd been living there for about six months. And now my brothers and I, we were allowed into the snake room, the snake house. And he would deal with the poisonous snakes, and we would deal with the nonpoisonous snakes and the pythons. So that was fun, and that was exciting, as you could imagine, for an 11-year-old boy, being watched behind the glass by his 80 classmates and teachers.
这意味着我要给维克打下手。我们已经在那里住了大约六个月了。现在我和兄弟们被允许进入蛇屋。他负责处理毒蛇，我们负责处理无毒蛇和蟒蛇。这很有趣，你可以想象，对于一个11岁的男孩来说，在80名同学和老师的众目睽睽下做这些事是多么令人兴奋。
Oh, right, you're going to seem like this brave kid dealing with snakes and getting to do something that's so cool.
哦，没错，你会显得像个勇敢的孩子，不仅能处理蛇，还能做这么酷的事情。
Yeah, totally cool, and I would be totally at home with it, because I was by that stage and loved doing it. Every weekend I would watch Vic do his shows. I knew them off by heart. And I just used to love standing there amongst the crowd every weekend and feeling everybody's amazement as he would milk the death adder and show the venom dripping down the glass. And Vic was fearless. That was his world. He was very, very comfortable handling snakes.
没错，简直太酷了，而且我会完全应付自如，因为那时候我已经很习惯了，而且很喜欢做这些。每个周末我都会看维克表演，对他那一套了如指掌。我过去每个周末都喜欢站在人群中，感受大家在他挤出死亡蛇毒液并展示毒液滴落在玻璃上时的惊叹。维克无所畏惧，那是他的世界，他处理蛇时非常非常从容。
And they came up, and all the kids piled out of the buses. And I got to saunter out to the buses and say hi to my teachers. And the day began. And so at a certain point, around the middle of the day, it was time to see the snake show. So then everybody's in the snake house. I'm in there with Vic putting the snakes in the bags. Everybody's watching us through the window.
他们来了，孩子们从校车上蜂拥而下。我有机会悠闲地走到车前和老师们打招呼，新的一天就这样开始了。大约到中午时分，到了看蛇表演的时间。于是大家都进了蛇屋，我和维克正在把蛇装进袋子里，大家都在窗外看着我们。
This is just prep for the show. They would put the snakes into bags, and then they would carry them to the stage for Vic's presentation.
这只是表演前的准备。他们会把蛇装进袋子里，然后带到舞台上供维克表演使用。
And all of a sudden, this incredible thing happens. Beside me, Vic picks up a tiger snake, the second-deadliest snake in Australia. And it bites him three times, tf, tf, tf, like that. And it made this little sort of thump, thump, thump sound on his hand as it bit him.
突然，一件不可思议的事情发生了。就在我身边，维克拿起了一条虎蛇，那是澳大利亚毒性排名第二的毒蛇。它咬了他三口，“噗、噗、噗”几下。蛇咬他时，他的手上发出了一种微弱的扑通扑通声。
Had you ever seen that before?
你以前见过这种情况吗？
No, no, nothing had ever gone wrong. I had never seen a snake bite a human being before. And now I saw it from one of the deadliest snakes in the world, and it was massively powerful, the moment of the bite. And it was a triple bite, bang, bang, bang. And Vic drops the snake, and he says, damn, and starts sucking the web of his hand where the snake bit him.
没有，从没出过差错。我以前从没见过蛇咬人。现在我亲眼目睹了世界上最毒的蛇之一咬人，那一刻爆发的力量感极强。那是连环三咬，砰、砰、砰。维克丢下蛇，咒骂了一声，开始吮吸虎蛇咬到的虎口位置。
And I'm completely astonished. I'm just on my knees, looking at him, thinking, what happens next? How bad is this? Well, I knew it was bad. I heard him give the talk every weekend about how bad the tiger snake bite is. And Vic says, listen, run down to the kiosk and get me a pint of milk.
我完全惊呆了。我跪在地上看着他，心里想：接下来会发生什么？情况有多严重？好吧，我知道这很严重。我每个周末都听他讲虎蛇咬人有多可怕。维克说：“听着，跑到小卖部给我买一品脱牛奶。”
So I say, OK, and I run out the door. And I've got a task, now, you know? And there's this little general store, kind of kiosk thing at the place. So I run down. I get the pint of milk. I say, this is for Vic. Like, I don't have to pay. This is the beginning of all the rules of the day being broken, you know? It's one of my clearest memories of this day, is how everything went the way it shouldn't have gone, and all bets were off.
我说：“好。”然后跑出了门。现在我有任务了，对吧？那里有一个小商店，算是小卖部之类的。我跑过去买了那品脱牛奶。我说：“这是给维克的。”就像这样，我不用付钱。你知道，这一天所有的规则都在被打破，这就是我对此日最清晰的记忆之一：所有事情的发展都偏离了轨道，一切常规都失效了。
I get the pint of milk. I run back up. He opens it, and he drinks this pint down, drinks the whole thing down in one long mouthful. And I say, so are you OK, Vic? And he's like, yeah, yeah, everything's fine, mate. Everything's fine. Let's do the show.
我拿到了那品脱牛奶跑回去。他打开瓶盖，一口气喝完了，长长的一口就喝光了整瓶。我说：“你没事吧，维克？”他说：“没事，没事，一切都好，伙计。一切都好。我们开始表演吧。”
And this is because like, milk is some sort of thing you do if you get bitten by a deadly snake?
这是因为喝牛奶被毒蛇咬后有什么奇效吗？
I think the milk thing was just one of those weird old wives tales or one of those Australian Bush recipes that this helps if you get bitten by a snake. So we're ready to go now. We have all the snakes in the bags, and we leave the snake house. And it's this weird Pied Piper kind of thing. It's me and Vic, weighed down with these little blue canvas bags filled with writhing snakes.
我觉得牛奶的事儿只是那些古怪的民间偏方，或者是澳大利亚丛林里的某种土办法，说是被蛇咬了喝这个有用。我们准备好了。把所有的蛇装进袋子，离开了蛇屋。那场景就像吹笛人带路一样古怪。我和维克走在前面，身上背着那些装着扭动蛇类的蓝色帆布袋。
And we all walk down to the snake platform where he gave the shows, followed by all of my classmates and our teachers, and the only other people there that day at the Butterfly Farm was a couple of busloads of kids in wheelchairs. They were kind of the spina bifida kids, or kids who are disabled in various ways. And they were there with their minders, these middle-aged women mostly, pushing these very disabled kids in wheelchairs. So they, too, are following us all down for the big snake show.
我们走到他表演的蛇台，后面跟着我所有的同学和老师。那天蝴蝶农场里唯一的其他访客是两车坐轮椅的孩子。他们大多是患有脊柱裂或其他残疾的孩子。他们由监护人陪伴，大多是中年妇女，推着这些严重残疾的孩子坐着轮椅。所以，他们也跟着我们去看大型蛇展。
And the snake platform was about the size of a boxing ring. It was a raised platform, and people would circle the platform on all four sides. And Vic begins the show. And he gets about 10 minutes into the show, and he's holding a green tree snake, which is a thin little whippet-like snake.
那个蛇台大约有拳击台那么大。这是一个抬高的平台，人们从四面围着它。维克开始了表演。表演进行到大约10分钟时，他正拿着一条绿树蛇，那是一种细长如鞭的小蛇。
And suddenly, he says, uh, ladies and gentlemen, I'm going to have to stop the show now, because-- and he's standing straight up, and his eyes glaze over. And he's instantly unconscious, that's clear, and he starts to fall backwards. And at the instant that he falls backwards, the snake in his hands, he releases it, and it falls over the edge of the platform and into the lap of one of these kids in a wheelchair and starts writhing around in the kid's lap.
突然，他说：“呃，女士们先生们，我不得不停止表演了，因为……”他站得笔直，双眼发直，瞬间失去了知觉，很明显，他开始向后倒去。在他向后倒下的一瞬间，他松开了手里的蛇，蛇掉到了平台边缘，正好掉在一个坐轮椅的孩子的怀里，开始在孩子身上扭动。
OK, crazy, and nobody knows what to do. The snake is on this child's lap. And because Vic has turned stiff as a board--
天哪，太疯狂了，没人知道该怎么办。蛇在那个孩子怀里。因为维克僵硬得像块木板——
He doesn't break his fall at all. He's completely unconscious from a standing position. And he hits the wooden platform with this thwack, this enormous thump, a horrible cracking sound of his head hitting the wood. So at the same instant, this kid in the wheelchair, this kid had sort of claw hands and so on, and he's looking down at the snake in his lap. And he starts to just go-- [MOANS] And everybody around the kid in the wheelchair just runs away screaming, including the lady who's looking after him.
他完全没有缓冲，直接从站立姿势昏迷倒地。他重重地摔在木制平台上，发出巨大的“啪”的一声，头部撞击木板的声音非常恐怖。就在同一瞬间，那个坐轮椅的孩子——那孩子的手有些畸形——正盯着怀里的蛇，开始发出……（呻吟声）。围在轮椅孩子周围的人全都尖叫着跑开了，包括照顾他的那位女士。
At the same instant, Vic has hit the ground, and his arms have spread out, and arms and legs spread in a kind of star shape. And I'm staring at him and the kid. And then I catch the eye of one of my teachers who's looking at me, as if to say, what's going on. So I have to act suddenly. There's this moment now where I suddenly realize that I'm the one with the greatest knowledge, and that my teachers, in a sense, are standing there powerless and beginning to be freaked out and not having a clue what to do. It was an amazing moment.
与此同时，维克摔倒在地，四肢张开，呈现一种大字型。我死死盯着他和那个孩子。然后我捕捉到了其中一位老师看向我的眼神，仿佛在问：到底发生了什么？所以我必须立刻行动。就在那一刻，我突然意识到，我是这里最了解情况的人，老师们在那儿显得手足无措，惊慌失措，完全不知道该怎么办。那一刻简直神奇。
And an amazing moment for a kid to have at 11. Like, when you're 11, you don't get many situations where you are the one, and adults need to look to you to take control of a situation.
对于一个11岁的孩子来说，这确实是一个惊人的时刻。当你是11岁时，很少能遇到这种你是主心骨，大人们需要依赖你来控制局面的情况。
Yeah. So I run over to the kid, and there's this moment where I look in his eye, and I say something like, it's OK. And I take the snake out of his lap in the way that I was taught to do, which is gently and without any jerky movements, and run up the stairs onto the platform. And that's the moment where I see how incredibly bad things are, in terms of Vic's state of health.
是的。我跑到那孩子身边，那一刻我看着他的眼睛说：“没事的。”我按照学过的方法，轻轻地、没有剧烈动作地把蛇从他怀里拿走，然后跑上台阶回到平台。就在那一刻，我看到维克的身体状况糟糕到了极点。
And so what does it look like?
看起来是什么样子？
First of all, it's horrendously embarrassing, because he's pissed his pants, this guy who I looked up to so much. And it's everywhere. The whole bottom half of his body is soaked, and it's all around him, spreading on these floorboards. It was very much no longer a matter of, this is so good for me because this might change my place in the pecking order amongst these difficult school kids in this difficult situation, but just a matter of, oh, my god, I think Vic's dying, or Vic's dead.
首先，这极其尴尬，因为他尿裤子了，这个我曾无比仰慕的人。到处都是。他下半身全湿透了，甚至流到了地板上。这早就不再是“这对我很有利，能改变我在那些顽劣同学中的地位”的问题了，而仅仅是——天哪，我觉得维克要死了，或者他已经死了。
His face is almost black by now. It's this kind of bruised purple-black color. So I put the snake back into the blue canvas bag and tied the knot the way Vic had taught me. And then I said to my teachers, I'll get my dad. And then I proceeded to sprint up the hill to the house, screaming at the top of my lungs, Dad, Dad, Dad!
他的脸已经变得乌黑，是一种淤青般的紫黑色。我把蛇放回蓝色帆布袋，并按维克教我的方式打好结。然后我对老师们说：“我去叫我爸爸。”接着我径直往山上的房子冲去，拼命尖叫着：“爸爸！爸爸！爸爸！”
It was a pretty far way to go. And he gets his dad, and Luke's dad came back with them. And when they got back, none of the adults had taken any action at all. One of Luke's teachers was kneeling next to Vic, but he wasn't administering CPR or doing mouth to mouth or anything at all. He was just kneeling there, not sure what to do.
那段路相当远。他找到了爸爸，卢克的爸爸随他们回来。当他们赶到时，大人们一点行动都没有。卢克的一位老师跪在维克旁边，但他既没有做心肺复苏，也没有做人工呼吸，什么都没做。他只是跪在那儿，不知所措。
Luke's dad lifted Vic's limp body into the car, tore off to the hospital. And that was it. Luke gathered up the snakes and put them back where they belonged.
卢克的爸爸把维克瘫软的身体抱进车里，飞奔向医院。事情就是这样。卢克收拾好蛇，把它们放回了该去的地方。
So Vic survived. But the incredibly sad thing was, that was the last snake show he ever gave in his life. He was on a kidney machine for three months. His skin took three months to gradually, gradually return back to its color. And that was it. Yeah. That was kind of, end of career.
维克活了下来。但极其悲伤的是，那是他一生中最后一场蛇展。他在医院里用了三个月的肾透析机。他的皮肤花了三个月才一点点、一点点地恢复原本的颜色。就这样，他的职业生涯结束了。
When I tell the story, even now, it's absolutely vivid, and it's always vivid in my gut, you know? All of the main moments of what happened that day are still in my gut. It's, to this day, one of the most vivid and intense memories in my life, because in some weird way, it was a turning point. It was one of those series of events heading towards adolescence and heading towards developing a concept of yourself as an autonomous human being, as an adult.
直到现在，当我讲起这个故事时，它依然无比生动，那种感觉始终萦绕在心头。那天发生的所有关键瞬间至今仍刻在我脑海里。直到今天，这依然是我人生中最生动、最强烈的记忆之一，因为在某种奇特的意义上，那是一个转折点。它是一系列事件，引领着我走向青春期，走向建立起一个自主个体的人格，走向成年。
And how often in your life do you have a moment where it suddenly becomes so utterly clear what you have to do and only you can do it?
在你的人生中，有多少次会遇到那种突然清晰地知道自己必须做什么，而且非你不可的时刻？
I think it's really rare. For me, that was it. That was that moment. I mean, I love every moment of my life. And without sounding pretentious, I hope it doesn't sound pretentious, but at some absolutely primal level, it was this deeply satisfying sense of actually doing something heroic.
我认为非常罕见。对我来说，那就是那一次。我是说，我热爱生命中的每一刻。我并不是想显得矫情，我希望这听起来不矫情，但在某种绝对原始的层面上，那是一种真正做了英雄之举的、深刻的满足感。
Well, today on our radio show, stories of people saving the day and what takes them over when they do it. And these stories of people who jump in are just seized by the sense that they have to act. They don't have a choice. They won't be able to live with themselves if they don't jump into action. There's something incredibly pure about it. Our show in two acts, one in the wilds of Mexico, one in the halls of academia. Stay with us.
好吧，今天我们的广播节目将讲述那些挽救危局的人们，以及他们行动时的心理状态。这些挺身而出的人被一种使命感所占据。他们别无选择，如果袖手旁观，他们将无法面对自己。这种感觉极其纯粹。我们的节目分两幕，第一幕发生在墨西哥的荒野，第二幕发生在学术殿堂。请留步。
Act 1, Midlife Cowboy. We have this story from James Spring, who lives in a city that's not so far from the Mexican border, San Diego.
第一幕，中年牛仔。我们带来詹姆斯·斯普林的故事，他住在离墨西哥边境不远的圣地亚哥。
At 39, I took a little inventory of my life and found myself to be unremarkable in almost every way. For more than a decade, I'd held a job writing ad copy in radio commercials in San Diego. I had a wife, two kids, two mortgages, TiVo, prescription reading glasses, and about 20 extra pounds that I no longer had the energy or ambition to lose. My 40th birthday was only a couple of months away in April.
39岁时，我盘点了自己的人生，发现自己在各方面都平庸无奇。十多年来，我一直在圣地亚哥做写商业电台广告的工作。我有妻子、两个孩子、两份抵押贷款、一台录像机、一副处方老花镜，还有大约20磅减不掉、也没精力去减的赘肉。我的40岁生日离4月只有几个月了。
My wife, Kelly, had a brighter attitude about it all. We'll throw you a big party, she said. It'll be fun. I don't think so, I said. I didn't want a party. It's your big 4-0, she said. Think about what you want to do for it. I did think about it, for a long time. In the end, what I thought was, I'm going to do something big to help somebody else in a big way. It's going to be a great big thing. And when it's done, I'm going to feel really, really good and helpful.
我妻子凯利对此态度更乐观。“我们会为你举办一场盛大的派对，”她说，“那会很有趣。”“我不这么认为，”我说。我不想要派对。“那是你重要的40岁生日，”她说，“想想你想做点什么。”我确实想了很久。最后，我想的是：我要做一件大事，去大大地帮助别人。那会是一件伟大的事。等做完后，我会感觉非常、非常好，很有成就感。
What do you mean help somebody, my wife said. I don't know, I said. It was still pretty shapeless inside my head. I used to be a boat captain. I knew parts of Mexico better than pretty much anybody. Maybe that was a start. Who are you going to help, my wife said. Help them what? I don't know, I said. Something's going to come up. Maybe an earthquake will hit, and I'll help dig people out. Maybe a helicopter will go down in Baja. I could help find it. This was all met with the most epic of eye-rolling and sighing.
“你说帮助别人是什么意思？”我妻子问。“我不知道，”我说。在我脑海里这还很模糊。我以前做过船长，我对墨西哥部分地区的了解比谁都多。也许这是个起点。“你要帮谁？”我妻子问，“帮他们什么？”“我不知道，”我说，“总会有什么事发生的。也许会发生地震，我去帮着挖人。也许会有直升机在下加州坠毁，我能帮着找。这番话换来的只有她无比夸张的翻白眼和叹气。
At least twice a week, this conversation continued to divide us. She'd talk about party planning, and I'd have to remind her that I might not even be around. I might be out, you know, rescuing people. April arrived and still no earthquakes or helicopters. So on Friday, about 5 o'clock, right after work, I thought, maybe I should be a little more proactive. I did a Google search on two words that seemed to make the most sense for my plan-- "Baja" and "missing."
这种对话每周至少发生两次，让我们产生分歧。她谈论派对策划，我不得不提醒她，我可能根本不在场，我可能正在外面救援。4月到了，依然没有地震或直升机坠毁。所以周五下午5点左右，刚下班，我想，我或许该主动点。我在谷歌上搜索了两个对我计划最有意义的词——“下加州”和“失踪”。
It might be time to explain the Baja part. In the late '80s, I worked in the area that the Drug Enforcement Agency calls the Western Mexico Baja Corridor. But I wasn't one of the good guys. It was over 20 years ago. I had just dropped out of college, and I was a little aimless. I reconnected with a friend that I'll call Alex, back in San Diego. Alex had put together an enterprise moving methamphetamine along the West Coast.
现在或许该解释一下下加州的部分。80年代末，我在缉毒署所称的墨西哥西部下加州走廊地区工作。但我不是好人。那是20多年前的事了。我刚退学，有点漫无目的。我联系上了我在圣地亚哥的一位朋友，姑且叫他亚历克斯。亚历克斯当时组建了一个沿西海岸运送甲基苯丙胺的企业。
Right about the time I arrived, a new law had been passed in the US that made it tough to get the main ingredient, ephedrine. But I was pretty sure we could still get it in Mexico. The border was less than a half hour away. The ephedrine pipeline was easy to establish, and soon it got filled with other stuff, too-- coke, marijuana. Personally, the drugs held no attraction for me, which made it easy to justify my actions. I mean, if these dirtbags wanted to ruin their lives with meth, let them.
我刚到时，美国刚通过一项法律，使得很难获得主要原料麻黄碱。但我很确定我们能在墨西哥弄到。边境离那儿不到半小时车程。麻黄碱运输线很容易建立，很快又加入了一些其他东西——可卡因、大麻。个人而言，我对这些毒品没兴趣，这让我很容易为自己的行为辩解。我的意思是，如果这些混蛋想用冰毒毁掉自己的生活，就随他们去吧。
It turned out I was really good at the job. I got to know my way around Mexico, around the marinas and hidden ranchos and dirt airstrips, around the cops and soldiers. I came to love the Baja Peninsula. But during this time, the business was falling apart back on the US side. Alex and his pals had developed bad drug habits, and they got really sloppy. I'd been away in Mexico during two police raids on the house in San Diego, but I was there for the third one.
事实证明，我非常擅长这份工作。我熟悉墨西哥的路，熟悉那些码头、隐藏的牧场、土跑道，熟悉警察和士兵。我开始爱上下加利福尼亚半岛。但在这期间，美国这边的业务正在崩溃。亚历克斯和他的同伙染上了严重的毒瘾，变得非常草率。圣地亚哥那栋房子遭到两次突袭时，我刚好在墨西哥，但第三次我在现场。
I was arrested and taken to jail with the others. But the cops didn't have a warrant, so they had to drop the charges. I moved out of the house. But a couple of weeks later, some bad guys came in the middle of the night, black sweatshirts, black ski masks.
我和其他人一起被捕入狱。但警察没有搜查令，所以他们不得不撤销指控。我搬离了那栋房子。但几周后，一些坏蛋在深夜闯入，穿着黑色卫衣，戴着黑色滑雪面罩。
They beat Alex into a coma, raped his girlfriend. They stole everything they could get their hands on. After that, I packed up my red Jeep and I drove south to Baja. I didn't come back for four years.
他们把亚历克斯打成了植物人，强奸了他的女友。他们偷走了能拿走的一切。在那之后，我装好我的红色吉普车，一路向南驶向下加州。我四年没回来。
By the time I moved back to San Diego in 1993, I'd fashioned myself into an upstanding citizen, an ambitious and enthusiastic member of the workforce. And life rolled along pretty much like I suppose it does for most people-- an HMO, a 401(k), a family. I kept waiting for the other shoe to drop, but life was really steady. It was good, far better than I deserved.
到1993年我搬回圣地亚哥时，我已经把自己塑造为一个正直的公民，一个雄心勃勃、充满干劲的职场成员。生活相当平稳，正如我所认为的大多数人的生活那样——医疗保险、401(k)退休计划、家庭。我一直等着靴子落地，但生活确实很稳定。这很好，远比我应得的要好。
And so, on the eve of my 40th birthday, I brought up Google and typed the words "Baja" and "missing." The top result on Google was a day-old newspaper article about a fugitive couple wanted for kidnapping and murder. The story, essentially, was that this couple, Richard Carelli and Michelle Pinkerton, were a pair of chronic meth heads who killed their landlord in San Francisco.
所以，在40岁生日的前夜，我打开谷歌，输入了“下加州”和“失踪”。谷歌最顶端的搜索结果是一篇发布于一天的报纸文章，关于一对因绑架和谋杀而被通缉的亡命鸳鸯。故事本质上是：这对夫妇，理查德·卡雷利和米歇尔·平克顿，是一对慢性冰毒瘾君子，他们在旧金山杀死了房东。
And then they drove to Santa Cruz and kidnapped their own six-year-old daughter from the grandparents who'd been given legal custody. And oh, yeah, also on the run with them, their two-month-old baby girl with Down syndrome. Clearly, these were not great parents. A year earlier they were holed up in a motel when police raided the room and found them with a pile of stolen property and methamphetamines.
然后他们开车前往圣克鲁斯，从获得了法律监护权的祖父母那里绑架了自己的六岁女儿。哦，是的，还有一个患有唐氏综合症的两个月大女婴也在逃亡中。显然，他们不是什么好父母。一年前，他们躲在一家汽车旅馆时，警察搜查了房间，发现了他们和一堆赃物以及冰毒。
Their daughter, Viana, then four years old, was found hiding under the motel bed. The newspaper picture of Viana showed a smiling little girl with blond hair and blue eyes and a dress with pink polka dots. She looked just like my daughter Addie. Police had been searching for Viana and her parents for more than three months. This article said that a month earlier a tourist might have spotted the family in a town called San Quintín on Baja California's Pacific coast.
他们的女儿维亚娜当时四岁，被发现躲在汽车旅馆的床下。报纸上维亚娜的照片显示，这是一个有着金发蓝眼、穿着粉色圆点连衣裙的微笑着的小女孩。她长得和我女儿阿迪一模一样。警方已经搜寻维亚娜和她父母三个多月了。这篇报道称，一个月前，一名游客可能在下加利福尼亚太平洋沿岸的一个叫圣昆廷的镇上发现了这一家人。
Meth head kidnapper murderers on the run-- I was a former meth supplier. I absolutely do not believe in destiny, but Jesus Christ. There was a link to a Missing flyer with pictures and a phone number to call. I dialed, and a switchboard operator answered for the San Francisco Police Department. I realized I had no idea what to say. Hi, I said, I'm calling about a flyer for a missing girl, Viana Carelli.
冰毒绑架谋杀犯在逃——我曾经是一个毒品供应商。我绝对不相信命运，但老天爷啊。网页上有一个带有失踪传单的链接，上面有照片和报警电话。我拨了过去，旧金山警察局的总机接线员接听了。我意识到我根本不知道该说什么。“喂，”我说，“我打电话是关于一张失踪女孩维亚娜·卡雷利的传单。”
A flyer sir, the operator said. Or I guess a poster, I said, like a Missing poster. Sir, do you know the whereabouts of a missing person? No, I said, I just want to he-- I just need to talk to somebody in charge of the Viana Carelli case. Can you spell that, sir? I spelled the name. She put me on hold three times. Obviously, I hadn't called the right person.
“传单，先生？”接线员问。“或者我猜是海报，”我说，“就像那种失踪人口海报。”“先生，你知道失踪者的下落吗？”“不，”我说，“我只是想……我就是需要和负责维亚娜·卡雷利案的人谈谈。”“你能拼写一下名字吗，先生？”我拼出了名字。她把我转接了三次。很显然，我找错人了。
I looked up other contact info for the San Francisco Police Department. I made a couple more calls and quickly realized I needed to fake a little more competence. Here's what I was going to say. Look, I'm certain that there's a team of officers and volunteers conducting canvassing and search parties. I would like to volunteer to join the effort. But the conversation never got that far.
我查了旧金山警察局的其他联系方式。我又打了几个电话，很快意识到我需要装得更称职一点。我是这样准备说的：看，我确信有一支由警官和志愿者组成的队伍正在进行搜查。我想申请加入这项工作。但对话从未达到那一步。
Instead, each time, nobody knew what I was talking about. I finally convinced somebody to transfer me to the Detectives division. I got an answering machine saying that the office was closed until Monday morning. The lack of information, the lack of interest by the police department was surprising-- unbelievable, really. This whole story had become front-page news because of the way the San Francisco police had already bungled it.
相反，每一次，对方都不知道我在说什么。我终于说服了一个人把我转到了侦探部门。我听到的是一台录音电话，说办公室要到周一早上才上班。警方缺乏信息、缺乏兴趣令人惊讶——简直不可思议。由于旧金山警察局之前的失误，整个故事已经变成了头条新闻。
The newspaper said that after Carelli and Pinkerton's landlord was reported missing, the police didn't respond for a month. And when they did finally arrive at his building to look for him, they found his tenants, Carelli and Pinkerton, unwilling to let them search the property. A police dog keyed on Carelli's van in the driveway. There were blood stains visible in the open garage, but the officers had no warrant.
报纸称，在卡雷利和平克顿的房东被报失踪后，警方一个月都没有反应。而当他们终于赶到房东的大楼寻找他时，他们发现租客卡雷利和平克顿拒绝让他们搜查房产。警犬在车道上卡雷利的货车上有了反应。开放的车库里有明显的血迹，但警官没有搜查令。
They allowed the couple to drive away in their beat-up white Mercury sedan. The cops eventually towed Carelli's van, but then, incredibly, they didn't search it. On the impound lot, somebody finally looked inside and found the body of the landlord. He'd been dead for six weeks.
他们任由这对夫妇开着那辆破旧的白色水星轿车离开了。警察最终拖走了卡雷利的货车，但不可思议的是，他们竟然没有搜查它。在扣押停车场，终于有人往里看了一眼，发现了房东的尸体。他已经死了六个星期了。
By this time, Carelli and Pinkerton were already hundreds of miles away. Cell phone records showed that they made it as far as Vegas, and then, for three months, nothing. So maybe the San Francisco police were not the best resource here. I looked online for volunteer groups, flyer passer-outers, candlelight vigils. Again, nothing.
到这时，卡雷利和平克顿已经跑到了几百英里之外。手机记录显示他们到了拉斯维加斯，然后，三个月来音信全无。所以也许旧金山警察并不是这里的最佳资源。我在网上寻找志愿者小组、发传单的、烛光守夜活动。又是一无所获。
All that was left at this point was the little girl's family, the grandparents and an uncle that the newspaper had called the family spokesman. Probably every nut job in the world was calling them, the smarmy investigators and the psychics, grifters, con men. I found the uncle's phone number and then just sort of dialed. It went exactly like you'd think it would, which is to say, badly. If your main objective in a conversation is to convince someone that you're not crazy, you've already lost.
此时只剩下女孩的家人了，祖父母和一位被报纸称为家庭发言人的叔叔。可能世界上所有的疯子都在给他们打电话，那些轻浮的调查员、通灵者、骗子、江湖郎中。我找到了那位叔叔的电话号码，然后就拨了过去。一切如你所料，糟糕透顶。如果你在谈话中的主要目的是让对方相信你不是疯子，那你已经输了。
Essentially, what the uncle said was, thank you for your concern. The police are doing everything they can. We appreciate the support. And then the call was over. I was on my own. To be honest, it felt sort of good, sort of familiar, but better, because I knew without a doubt that this was the right thing to do. I was going to Baja. Now I just had to go home and tell my wife.
本质上，那位叔叔说的是：谢谢你的关心。警方正在尽他们所能，我们感谢你的支持。通话就此结束。我孤身一人。老实说，这感觉还不错，有一种熟悉感，但更好，因为我毫无疑问地知道这是正确的事。我要去下加州。现在我只需要回家告诉我妻子。
She wasn't happy. You said you were going to help people in an earthquake, she said. This isn't our problem. This isn't your fight. She was crying and yelling. They're drug addicts. They're murderers. She spent a long time listing reasons why I shouldn't go.
她不高兴。“你说过要去地震中救人，”她说，“这不是我们的问题，这不是你的战斗。”她在哭喊。他们是瘾君子，是谋杀犯。她列举了很长时间我不应该去的理由。
I understood why she was worried. Baja's rough. Every couple of weeks, there's another string of beheadings or a government official hung from a bridge, usually thanks to the drug cartels. Last year, a guy nicknamed [SPEAKING SPANISH], the Stew Maker, confessed to dissolving the bodies of more than 300 of his victims in acid. These stories helped keep Baja pristine, free of tourists, free of development, free of laws.
我明白她为什么担心。下加州很乱。每隔几周，就会有一串斩首事件，或者政府官员被吊在桥上，这通常是毒贩集团干的。去年，一个绰号“炖肉匠”的家伙承认用酸溶解了300多名受害者的尸体。这些故事让下加州远离了游客、远离了开发、远离了法律。
It's like the old Wild West. And like the Old West, there's no cell phone service, so Kelly knew she couldn't even call me down there. I kept repeating the one thing she couldn't argue with. Nobody's looking for those little girls, I said. If I don't go, who will?
就像旧西部的拓荒时期。像旧西部一样，那里没有手机信号，所以凯利知道她在那里甚至没法联系我。我不断重复着那句她无法反驳的话：“没人找那两个小女孩，”我说，“我不去，谁去？”
The next day, Saturday, I packed-- gas cans, topo maps, GPS, water jugs, fix-a-flat. I sent an email to my boss saying that something sudden had come up and that I'd be taking a vacation week, or maybe two. I took the lousy Missing flyer that I'd found online and redesigned it. I added a picture of the infant and a photo of a car from the Autotrader that matched Richard Carelli's white Mercury. I translated the flyer to Spanish and changed the headline to read [SPEAKING SPANISH], which means kidnapped. I went to Kinko's and printed 2,500 copies.
第二天，周六，我收拾行囊——油桶、地形图、GPS、水桶、补胎剂。我给老板发了邮件，说突然有急事，我要请一周甚至两周假。我把我从网上找到的那张糟糕的失踪传单重新设计了一下。我加了一张婴儿的照片和一张我从Autotrader网站上找的、与理查德·卡雷利的白色水星相匹配的汽车照片。我把传单翻译成西班牙语，并将标题改为“绑架”。我去了Kinko's打印了2500份。
Baja, California itself is a dusty peninsula that begins near the San Diego-Tijuana border and ends 1,000 miles later in the resort town of Cabo San Lucas. There's only one road that runs from top to bottom. And at various points along the way, it passes tiny villages and military checkpoints, and about two dozen of the state-run Pemex gas stations. Without much to go on, this is what I chose to believe.
下加利福尼亚本身是一个尘土飞扬的半岛，从圣地亚哥与蒂华纳边境附近开始，一千英里后在旅游胜地卡波圣卢卡斯结束。只有一条从头到尾的公路。一路上，它经过无数小村庄、军事检查站，以及大约两打州立Pemex加油站。没有太多线索，我选择了这么认为：
Richard Carelli knew nothing of Baja. He spoke no Spanish and had no friends. He had no weapons at this point and no money. The family was still traveling in the Mercury sedan. They would not willingly double-back through military checkpoints or cross into areas where they'd be required to show ID and register. Between the beat-up sedan and the newborn, they had to be somewhere close to the highway.
理查德·卡雷利对下加州一无所知。他不会说西班牙语，也没有朋友。此时他没有武器，没有钱。一家人依然开着那辆水星轿车。他们不会愿意经过军事检查站返回，也不会进入需要出示证件和登记的地区。带着破旧的轿车和新生儿，他们一定就在公路附近。
I spent the first day passing out flyers at gas stations, at police stations, at military checkpoints, where I also passed out old Playboy magazines I had put in my truck to grease the skids with soldiers, a trick I resurrected from the old days. I made countless stops and starts. At every market and rancho near a dusty crossroads, I told the story. Not a single person had heard it before, but they were all titillated now by the drama of the murderous couple and their poor children.
第一天我都在加油站、警察局、军事检查站散发传单。在检查站，我还散发了我放在货车里的旧《花花公子》杂志来讨好士兵，这是我从旧时代复活的伎俩。我无数次走走停停。在尘土飞扬的十字路口附近的每一个市场和牧场，我都讲述了这个故事。没有人听说过，但现在他们都对这起谋杀夫妇及其可怜孩子的戏剧性事件感到兴奋不已。
Just before dark, I arrived in San Quintín, the town where the couple might have been spotted a month earlier. Taco stands, bars, hotels, campgrounds, nobody had seen or heard of the family. I went to bed sometime around midnight, but I couldn't fall asleep. I lay on the lumpy mattress and tried to envision every possibility.
天黑前，我到达了圣昆廷，一个月前这对夫妇可能被发现的镇子。塔可饼摊、酒吧、酒店、露营地，没人见过或听说过这一家人。我午夜左右上床，但睡不着。我躺在坑坑洼洼的床垫上，试图设想所有的可能性。
Were Carelli and Pinkerton living in a village? Had they squatted in an abandoned ranch? Had they found a benefactor? Were they already dead? I wondered if maybe I was insane to be here. And some time, before I fell asleep, it hit me that they might not even have come to Mexico at all.
卡雷利和平克顿是住在村子里吗？他们是躲在废弃的牧场里吗？他们找到资助人了吗？他们已经死了吗？我怀疑我来到这里是不是疯了。在睡着之前，我突然想到他们可能根本没来过墨西哥。
The next morning, I woke to the sounds of roosters, day two. I got in my truck and headed south. I had my doubts, but I figured I had to keep going. An hour later, I came to a tiny farming community called Santa Maria. I went into a market and left a stack of flyers. A small group of men was milling around a pot of coffee. When I went back outside to the gas pumps, the guy who ran the market came out with one of the flyers in his hand.
第二天早上，我在公鸡的叫声中醒来。我开着货车向南前进。我有疑问，但我认为必须继续走。一小时后，我来到一个叫圣玛丽亚的小农耕社区。我走进市场，放下了一叠传单。一小群人在一壶咖啡旁磨蹭。当我走回外面的加油泵时，市场老板拿着一张传单出来了。
These people, he said, they were here. Really, I said. Somehow I doubted it. He looked at the flyer again. They bought water, milk, and potato chips. They asked if we sold diapers, but we don't. His grocery list was so specific. They were here. They had to be.
“这些人，”他说，“他们在这儿出现过。”“真的吗？”我说。我不由得怀疑。“他们来过，”他看着传单说，“他们买了水、牛奶和薯条。他们问我们卖不卖尿布，但我们没卖。”他的购物清单如此具体。他们来过。他们一定在这儿。
What vehicle were they driving, I asked. This one. He pointed at the flyer. How long ago? Three weeks. The timing was exactly right. Did you see the children, I asked. No, he said. I thanked him and left with a new plan. I would race straight down to the Baja Sur state line, the halfway point of the peninsula where the family would be forced to register.
“他们开什么车？”我问。“这一辆。”他指着传单。“多久以前？”“三周。”时间完全对得上。“你看到孩子们了吗？”我问。“没有，”他说。我谢过他，带着新的计划离开。我要直奔下加州州界，那是半岛的中点，在那里这家人必须登记。
I would bribe the immigration officials for a peek at the book and confirm that Carelli and Pinkerton didn't sneak past. And then I'd double back, and they'd scoop them up like a net. I was driving so fast now that the tire squealed on the turns. Before a half hour passed, I reached the village of El Rosario. The Pemex station there could be the last gas for 200 miles.
我要贿赂移民官员看一眼登记册，确认卡雷利和平克顿没有溜过去。然后我会绕回来，像网一样把他们兜住。我现在开得飞快，转弯时轮胎发出尖叫。不到半小时，我到了埃尔罗萨里奥村。那里的Pemex站可能是接下来200英里的最后一个加油站。
I'd probably filled my tank in El Rosario 300 times. It was too important a place to not stop for a minute and hang some flyers. I jammed on the brakes and skidded across the lane into the gas station. I was posting a flyer near a gas pump when one of the attendants approached.
我在埃尔罗萨里奥加过300次油。这是一个太重要的地方，不能不停车挂几张传单。我猛踩刹车，滑过车道冲进加油站。我正在一个加油泵附近贴传单时，一个服务员走近了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH], he said. I saw her, the blonde. Where, I asked. At pump number one, he said. She asked me about a cheap place to eat. When, I said. Three days ago. Three days, I said. You mean three weeks? Days, he said, three days ago.
“我看到了，那个金发女，”他说。“在哪儿？”我问。“在1号泵，”他说，“她问我哪里有便宜的饭吃。”“什么时候？”我问。“三天前。”“三天？”我说，“你是说三周？”“天，”他说，“三天前。”
Next door to the gas station was a small motel. I showed the flyer to the two ladies working behind the reception desk. When they saw it, they both shrieked and covered their mouths. Yes, the family was here in El Rosario. They were living in a small house just two doors away from the home of one of the receptionists. Yes, they were still driving the white car, but they'd been trying to sell it in the village.
加油站隔壁是一家小旅馆。我给前台工作的两位女士看了传单。当她们看到时，两人都尖叫起来，捂住了嘴。没错，这一家人就在埃尔罗萨里奥。他们住在一间离其中一位前台家里仅两扇门远的小房子里。没错，他们依然开着那辆白车，但他们一直在村里试图卖掉它。
And yes, the little girls were still with them. But the infant, whose name was Faith, was very sick. The blonde woman, they told me, was earning money by teaching dance lessons to children in the village for 10 pesos an hour, $1 an hour. The house was 100 meters away, less. What time are the classes, I asked. 3 o'clock, one of them said. I looked at my watch. It was 2:45.
没错，小女孩们依然和他们在一起。但那个名叫费思的婴儿病得很重。她们告诉我，那个金发女人靠给村里的孩子上舞蹈课赚钱，每小时10比索，即1美元。那房子就在100米外，甚至更近。我看着手表，2点45分，“课几点开始？”“3点，”其中一人说。
Carelli and Pinkerton were here, now, a block away. Things were moving so fast through my head that it felt like Earth time had stopped. I could suddenly see everything that I needed to do next so clearly. I told the women at the motel not to tell anyone about our conversation. I ran back to the gas station and ripped down the flyers and took back the stack I'd left. I needed to get my truck and its American license plates off the road fast. It was a tiny town. I had to assume that word would soon get back to Carelli and Pinkerton.
卡雷利和平克顿就在这里，现在，就在一个街区外。脑子里的东西转得太快，感觉地球时间停止了。我突然清楚地看到了接下来需要做的所有事。我告诉旅馆里的女人们不要把我们的谈话告诉任何人。我跑回加油站，撕掉传单，收回我留下的那一叠。我需要快点把我的货车和它的美国车牌从路上移走。这是一个小镇，我必须假定消息很快就会传到卡雷利和平克顿耳朵里。
I drove a half block to the town's small payphone office and hid my car behind the building. An operator connected me to the uncle in Santa Cruz. I found them, I said. I told him the story as quickly as I could. He gave me a phone number for a US marshal handling the case, and I got him on the phone. I found them, I said. The US marshal seemed doubtful, annoyed.
我开车到半个街区外的公共电话亭，把车藏在建筑后面。接线员把我连线到圣克鲁斯的叔叔。“我找到他们了，”我说。我尽快讲完了故事。他给了我一个负责此案的美国法警的电话，我联系上了他。“我找到他们了，”我说。美国法警似乎很怀疑，甚至有点恼火。
I let him know that I could get together a team of local police and go get Carelli. Don't do anything, he said. Call me back in one hour. I looked at my watch again. It was now after 3 o'clock. Dance class was in session. If I called the US marshal back in an hour, and he instructed me to contact the local cops-- which was the only reasonable option-- that whole process might take another hour, maybe more. And it might be too late.
我让他知道我可以组织一队当地警察去抓卡雷利。“什么都别做，”他说，“一小时后再给我打电话。”我又看了一次手表，现在已经过了3点。舞蹈课开始了。如果我一小时后再打给美国法警，让他指示当地警察——这是唯一合理的选择——整个过程可能要再花一小时，甚至更久。可能就太迟了。
I went across the street to the cinder block police station. Three cops were gathered around a small television watching a movie with Chuck Norris and a midget. I later figured out that the movie was Lone Wolf McQuade, the 1983 classic in which Chuck Norris's character makes an incursion into Mexico to take care of business.
我穿过马路来到那个煤渣块砌成的警察局。三名警察聚在一台小电视机前，看一部查克·诺里斯主演的动作电影。后来我发现那部电影是《孤胆英雄》，1983年的经典之作，查克·诺里斯扮演的角色闯入墨西哥处理事务。
Hey, partner, where are you headed?
“嘿，伙计，你要去哪？”
Mexico.
“墨西哥。”
Mexico? What the hell for?
“墨西哥？去那儿干什么？”
They got my daughter.
“他们抓了我的女儿。”
Well, hold on, I'm coming.
“好吧，坚持住，我来了。”
It's not your fight.
“这不是你的战斗。”
[ENGINE STARTING AND TIRES SQUEALING]
（引擎启动，轮胎尖叫声）
I need to speak with the comandante, I said. One of the cops leaned back in his chair. I'm the comandante. What do you want? He was clearly irritated by the interruption, but he led me to a tiny room with a metal desk and closed the door.
“我需要和指挥官谈谈，”我说。其中一个警察靠在椅背上。“我就是指挥官。你想要什么？”他对被打扰显然很恼火，但他还是把我带到一个带金属桌的小房间并关上了门。
When I'd finished telling him the story, he radioed his off-duty cops and told them to report to the station immediately. They called for backup from San Quintín. The dance class was half over. In the police station, bulletproof vests were pulled from lockers. Weapons were loaded. One of the cops found an extra flak jacket that would fit me.
当我讲完故事时，他用无线电召集了休班的警察，让他们立即向车站报告。他们呼叫了圣昆廷的增援。舞蹈课进行了一半。警察局里，防弹衣从柜子里拿出来。武器装填完毕。其中一名警察找到一件适合我的额外防弹衣。
At the one-hour mark, I dialed the US marshal from the telephone in the police station. It's no good, he said. The paperwork's not in order. He told me we'd have to wait until tomorrow. There will be no tomorrow, I said. There are two white men in this town, Richard Carelli and me. Pretty soon, he's going to know it, if he doesn't already. And then, he's going to do whatever it takes to run again.
在一小时的时候，我用警察局的电话拨通了美国法警。“不行，”他说，“手续不齐。”他告诉我我们必须等到明天。“没有明天了，”我说，“这个镇上有两个白人，理查德·卡雷利和我。很快他就会知道这一点，如果他还没察觉的话。然后，他会不计代价地再次逃亡。”
The marshal exhaled sharply. Ugh, he said. Call me in a half hour. You got to be kidding me, I thought. The Mexican cops stood all around me waiting for the word. I told them that I needed to make one more phone call. I dialed the uncle in Santa Cruz.
法警尖锐地呼了一口气。“嗯，”他说，“半小时后再打给我。”“你一定在开玩笑，”我想。墨西哥警察站在我周围等待指令。我告诉他们我需要再打一个电话。我拨通了圣克鲁斯的叔叔。
Look, I said. The US marshal says that we have to wait until tomorrow. I explained that it didn't have to be this way, that I didn't work for the US Marshal. But this wasn't my decision. It was his family. Only he could decide. He conferred for a few moments with the grandparents. And then he said, the paperwork will be ready by the time it's needed. Go do it.
“看，”我说，“美国法警说我们必须等到明天。”我解释说不一定非要这样，我不是美国法警的员工。但这也不是我的决定，这是他家人的事。只有他能决定。他和祖父母商量了片刻，然后他说：“需要的时候手续就会准备好的，去吧。”
Mexican federal cops arrived from San Quintín a few moments later, four unmarked truckloads full of guys with big mustaches and leather jackets. Most of them carried assault rifles. One of the trucks was sent out to observe the house. They radioed back to the station that the children were out front with the mother. A few seconds later came the report that the father was now outside, too.
墨西哥联邦警察几分钟后从圣昆廷赶到，四辆没标记的卡车，坐满了留着大胡子、穿着皮夹克的伙计。他们大多数拿着突击步枪。其中一辆卡车被派去监视房子。他们通过无线电报告说孩子们正和母亲在外面。几秒钟后传来消息，父亲也出去了。
The leader of the federal squad said, vamonos. Then he put a hand on my chest and ordered me to stay put. 10 minutes later, they returned. Michelle Pinkerton and the children were in the back of one truck. Carelli was handcuffed in another.
联邦小队队长说：“走吧。”然后他把一只手放在我胸口，命令我待在原地。10分钟后，他们回来了。米歇尔·平克顿和孩子们在其中一辆卡车后排。卡雷利被戴上手铐在另一辆里。
They jerked him out of his seat and stood him in front of me. And when he saw me, the fight drained out of him. Any fantasy he might have held about the arrest being just a Mexican shakedown was dead. He asked me why he was being arrested. I didn't respond. Viana stared out the door of the other truck, wide-eyed and nervous.
他们把他拽出座位，站在我面前。当他看到我时，他的斗志泄了。他可能抱有的任何关于这次逮捕只是墨西哥式勒索的幻想都破灭了。他问我他为什么被捕。我没回答。维亚娜从另一辆车的窗户向外看，睁大眼睛，神情紧张。
Michelle Pinkerton was working hard to convince her daughter that everything was OK. She held the baby tightly in one arm and hugged Viana with the other, rocking them both gently against her. We caravaned back to the federal headquarters, where a big group of cops whooped as Richard Carelli was pulled from the truck and led up to the station.
米歇尔·平克顿正努力让女儿相信一切都会好起来。她用一只手臂紧紧抱着婴儿，另一只搂着维亚娜，轻轻摇晃着她们。我们车队回到联邦总部，一大群警察欢呼着，卡雷利被从车里拽出来领向局里。
Michelle and the girls were taken out of the other truck, and Viana watched in horror as her father was led through the doors. She moved onto the sidewalk and stood next to me. She was really dirty, but she seemed healthy. Hi, I said. Hola, she said. Speaking Spanish now, huh? Si. You OK? Si.
米歇尔和女孩们从另一辆车被带下来，维亚娜惊恐地看着父亲被带进大门。她走到人行道上站在我旁边。她真的很脏，但看起来很健康。“嗨，”我说。“Hola，”她说。“现在说西班牙语了，嗯？”“Si。”“你没事吧？”“Si。”
The cops asked me to wait in one of the offices with Michelle and the girls. Viana kept asking about her father. Michelle assured her that he was fine. She was trying to find another blanket to wrap around Faith. The infant was so tiny, and her breathing was raspy. Michelle did everything she could to not look at me.
警察让我和米歇尔及孩子们在办公室等。维亚娜一直问她父亲的事。米歇尔向她保证他没事。她正试图找另一条毯子裹住费思。婴儿太小了，呼吸声嘶哑。米歇尔尽一切努力不去看我。
I sat for a long time, just watching her trying to stave off this new reality. Viana leaned over Faith and kissed her forehead. The baby cooed, and Viana laughed. And Michelle draped her arms around her daughters, and she smiled a smile so sad that I had to look away.
我坐了很久，看着她试图抵御这个新现实。维亚娜俯身吻了吻费思的前额。婴儿发出咕咕声，维亚娜笑了。米歇尔搂住女儿们，露出了一个悲伤到极点的笑容，我不得不移开目光。
Carelli was next door in a jail cell. He called to me, sir, excuse me sir. Can you please tell me why we're here? Sir, please. One of the cops entered the office where we sat and grabbed a leg shackle, this heavy black iron thing that looked like it belonged in a dungeon. He carried it to Carelli's cell. Viana started to cry.
卡雷利在隔壁牢房里。他呼唤我：“先生，打扰一下，先生。请问我们为什么在这儿？先生，拜托。”一名警察进入办公室，拿走了一副脚镣，那是沉重的黑色铁器，看起来像是地牢里的东西。他把它带到卡雷利的牢房。维亚娜开始哭泣。
I have a daughter, I said to her. She's four. She looks just like you. She likes to play princess. Do you play princess, too? Viana nodded. Michelle straightened up in her chair and asked me, are you from here? No, I said. I'm from California. Her eyes teared up and she nodded. Yeah.
“我有个女儿，”我对她说，“她四岁。长得和你一模一样。她喜欢当公主。你也当公主吗？”维亚娜点点头。米歇尔挺直腰板问我：“你是这儿的人吗？”“不，”我说，“我来自加州。”她眼中涌出泪水，点了点头，“是的。”
This was not what I signed up for. She just seemed like a mom. Where was the screaming, the blaming, the meth head excuses? Where was all the horrible parenting? Had they all been cured by their time here? Suddenly, I didn't really feel like I was riding in on the white horse. I just felt like I was meddling with somebody's family. What right did I have to upend the lives of these two little girls?
这并不是我想要参与的。她看起来只是个母亲。尖叫呢？责备呢？冰毒瘾君子的借口呢？那种糟糕的育儿方式在哪儿？她们在这里的时间治愈了这一切吗？突然间，我觉得自己根本不像骑着白马来的救世主。我只是在干预别人的家庭。我有什么权利打乱这两个小女孩的生活？
What does the baby need, I asked, diapers? Michelle nodded. Yeah, and formula. I drove into town and bought way too many baby supplies and some stuff for Viana, too. Then I stopped at a taco stand and bought three dozen carne asada tacos. Viana lit up when she saw the food. Did you bring food for my daddy, too?
“婴儿需要什么？”我问，“尿布？”米歇尔点点头，“是的，还有配方奶。”我开车进城，买了太多的婴儿用品，也给维亚娜买了一些。然后我在塔可饼摊停下，买了三打烤肉塔可饼。维亚娜看到食物时亮了起来。“你也给我爸爸带吃的了吗？”
I asked the cops if it was OK for her to deliver tacos to her father. I helped Viana make a plate and then followed her to the cell where Carelli was cuffed to the bars. Hi, honey, he said. Are you OK? She nodded. He held her face in his hands and kissed the top of her head through the bars. They spoke softly for a few minutes.
我问警察她是否可以给父亲送塔可饼。我帮维亚娜装了个盘子，跟着她走到卡雷利被铐在栅栏上的牢房。“嗨，宝贝，”他说，“你没事吧？”她点了点头。他隔着栅栏双手捧住她的脸，亲吻她的头顶。他们轻声交谈了几分钟。
I tried to fade as far away as I could. Carelli fought to keep it together. He looked up at me. Are you a bounty hunter? No, I said. What are you? I'm just a guy trying to help. He seemed to hold this for a long moment. Thank you, he said. I looked down. Yeah.
我尽量走得越远越好。卡雷利努力保持镇定。他抬头看着我，“你是赏金猎人吗？”“不，”我说。“你是什么？”“我只是个想帮点忙的普通人。”他似乎沉默了良久。“谢谢，”他说。我低下了头，“没关系。”
I called the uncle in Santa Cruz, tried to explain what I'd seen. The girls seemed well cared for, that they seemed loved. I told him that things were different than I had expected. Well, he said, Viana loves her grandparents, too.
我给圣克鲁斯的叔叔打了电话，试图解释我的所见。女孩们似乎得到了很好的照顾，她们似乎被爱着。我告诉他情况和我想象的不同。“好吧，”他说，“维亚娜也爱她的祖父母。”
I drove home the next day. I didn't know it yet, but the media was already in a full frenzy. CNN and CBS and Fox were calling my office. All the news reports were pretty black and white.
第二天我开车回家。我当时还不知道，媒体已经进入了狂热状态。CNN、CBS和福克斯都在打我办公室的电话。所有的报道都是非黑即白的。
--relatives. And after a whole month, police had no luck finding the girls. But one guy did in just two days. James Spring, who's also--
——亲属。整整一个月，警方毫无头绪。但一个人只用了两天就找到了。詹姆斯·斯普林，他也是——
They were calling me a hero, but I didn't feel like one.
他们称我为英雄，但我一点也不觉得。
All right, James. I'm so--
好吧，詹姆斯。我真的——
In a lot of ways, I felt like a homewrecker. I did a couple of interviews, but they went poorly.
在很多方面，我觉得自己像个家庭破碎的制造者。我接受了几次采访，但效果不佳。
How in the world did you pull this off? You went to Mexico, and what did you do?
你是怎么做到的？你去墨西哥，然后做了什么？
Basically, I created a flyer in Spanish. And the thing about the Baja--
基本上，我做了一张西班牙语传单。关于下加州那点事——
So I stopped. The one bright spot in all the coverage, the one moment that made me feel like maybe I had done the right thing was some video shot at the airport when Viana got off the plane in the US.
所以我停下了。所有报道中唯一闪光的时刻，唯一让我觉得也许我做了正确的事的瞬间，是维亚娜在美国机场下飞机时拍摄的一段视频。
Grandma!
“奶奶！”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Oh!
“哦！”
In it, Viana sees her grandmother at the arrival gate, and she yells Grandma and runs into her arms. And they're both crying.
视频里，维亚娜在到达口看到奶奶，大叫着冲进她的怀抱。她们都在哭。
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
OK, you're home now, OK?
“好了，你现在回家了，好吗？”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
The grandma tells her, it's OK, you're home now.
奶奶告诉她：“没事的，你回家了。”
It's been a hard time, huh?
“这段时间很难熬吧？”
I must have watched that video 100 times. All week, the phone calls didn't stop. Producers were trying to buy the movie rights. Long-lost relatives tried to reconnect. Everybody was calling, except Viana's grandparents.
我一定看了那段视频100遍。整整一周，电话没停过。制片人想买电影版权，失散已久的亲戚想来认亲。每个人都在打电话，除了维亚娜的祖父母。
I'd been thinking of them a lot. I just wanted to know that the girls were happy. Not happy, but you know, that they were OK, that they were going to be OK. But the grandparents didn't call, and I couldn't call them. They had to be overwhelmed. I felt like maybe I'd intruded into the girls' lives enough already. But I needed to do something.
我想过他们很多次。我只想知道女孩们是否幸福。不是幸福，而是说，你知道，她们还好，她们会没事的。但祖父母没打来，我也不能打给他们。他们一定不堪重负。我觉得自己或许已经干涉了女孩们的生活够多了。但我必须做点什么。
I sent a huge box of presents to the kids and a notebook for Viana, so she could write letters to her parents. On the inside cover, I wrote her a note. I tried to make her understand why I'd done this. It was kind of an explanation, kind of an apology, even though I knew she was way too young to comprehend any of it. I got no response.
我给孩子们寄了一大箱礼物，还给维亚娜寄了一个笔记本，让她可以写信给父母。在封面内侧，我给她写了张便条。我试图让她明白我为什么要这么做。那既是解释，也是道歉，尽管我知道她太小了，根本无法理解。我没得到回应。
And then I started learning some odd things. On one newspaper's website, I found a comment from a guy who said he was Michelle Pinkerton's brother. He called her white trash, said that he hopes she was brought to justice for her crimes. A reporter told me that he'd interviewed the grandfather and that the guy had made some pretty hateful remarks about Richard Carelli, about hoping that Carelli would become some big black guy's girlfriend in prison.
然后我开始得知一些古怪的事情。在一家报纸的网站上，我发现一个评论，那人说他是米歇尔·平克顿的哥哥。他称她为“白人垃圾”，说希望她能为自己的罪行受到制裁。一位记者告诉我，他采访了祖父，那人对理查德·卡雷利发表了一些充满仇恨的言论，说希望卡雷利在监狱里成为某个大块头黑人的女朋友。
And then there was a photographer who'd been sent to take pictures of the family who gave an equally depressing report. He said he couldn't shoot any photos in the house, because it didn't look like children even lived there-- no toys, no kid stuff on the walls. Of course, that doesn't mean anything. It's just cosmetic.
还有一个被派去给这家人拍照的摄影师也发回了同样令人沮丧的报告。他说他在屋里没法拍照，因为那看起来根本不像有孩子住——没玩具，墙上没孩子的装饰。当然，那说明不了什么。那只是表象。
It didn't mean they weren't taking good care of them or didn't love them. I didn't know what to believe. I was worried about those little girls, and nothing I'd heard since Baja was making me feel any better.
这并不意味着他们没照顾好孩子或不爱她们。我不知道该相信什么。我为那两个小女孩担心，自下加州之后我听到的任何事情都让我感觉没好一点。
Eight months passed. A trial date was set. And then one day, in the middle of the week, I got a call from Viana's grandfather. It wasn't a thank you, but it was like a, man, that thing you did in Mexico was really something. And I said, yeah? And then he reiterated his hopes that Viana's father be raped in prison every day for the rest of his life.
八个月过去了。审判日期确定了。有一天，在周中，我接到了维亚娜祖父的电话。那不是感谢，就像是——伙计，你在墨西哥做的那些事真的很特别。我说：“是吗？”然后他重申希望维亚娜的父亲在监狱里每天余生都被强奸。
He told me that the trial was about to begin, that I might get some phone calls from prosecutors. And then the call was over. Carelli was charged with first-degree murder. He admitted the landlord had died during a fight they had but said it was unintentional.
他告诉我审判要开始了，我可能会接到检察官的电话。通话结束了。卡雷利被控一级谋杀。他承认房东是在他们的一次争吵中死亡的，但说是无意的。
At trial, the details came out. The landlord's lip was busted open. His nose was broken. He was badly bruised and had been stabbed with a small knife. His body was found wrapped in a sleeping bag bound with duct tape and buried under a pile of trash in the back of the van. The official cause of death was suffocation.
在审判中，细节曝光了。房东的嘴唇被打破，鼻子骨折，浑身淤青，被一把小刀捅伤。尸体被发现裹在睡袋里，用胶带捆住，埋在货车后的一堆垃圾下。死因是窒息。
The defense argued that meth had given Carelli a condition called hypofrontality, meaning he couldn't think straight, so he made wacky decisions, like storing a corpse in his van and kidnapping his daughter and fleeing to Baja. In other words, the meth made him do it, which, as a former meth smuggler, didn't make me feel so great. The trial ended with a hung jury, so Richard Carelli wasn't convicted of first-degree murder. He'd have to be retried on a lesser charge.
辩方辩称，冰毒给了卡雷利一种叫“额叶功能减退”的症状，意味着他无法清晰思考，所以才做出疯狂决定，比如把尸体藏在货车里，绑架女儿并逃亡下加州。换句话说，是冰毒让他这么做的，作为一个前冰毒走私贩，这让我感觉很不好。审判以悬案告终，理查德·卡雷利没被定罪一级谋杀。他得在较轻的罪名下接受重审。
At some point, I got a phone call from a private investigator. Michelle Pinkerton's public defender had hired the guy to track me down. Miss Pinkerton says that you spent a couple of days with her and the kids in Mexico, he said. I told him that seemed a strange way to describe it. Did you see her, he asked, interacting with the children? I told him that I did. Well, she was thinking you might have some good things to say about what you saw there.
后来，我接到了一个私人侦探的电话。米歇尔·平克顿的公设辩护律师雇他来找我。“平克顿小姐说你在墨西哥和她及孩子们待了几天，”他说。我告诉他那听起来描述得很奇怪。“你看到她和孩子们互动了吗？”我告诉他我看过。他说：“好吧，她想或许你对你在那儿看到的一切有话要说。”
It took me a moment to understand that I'd just been asked to be the character witness for a meth addict and accused murderer who had taken her kids on the run. And in a way, I was really tempted, because she did seem like a good mother on that day, a mother who loved her kids, anyway, and whose kids loved her. But I couldn't do it.
我花了一会儿才明白，我刚刚被要求为一名冰毒瘾君子和被指控的谋杀犯充当品格证人，她还是个带着孩子逃亡的人。在某种程度上，我真的很心动，因为在那一天她确实看起来像个好母亲，至少是个爱孩子的母亲，而且她的孩子也爱她。但我做不到。
None of this had really turned out like it was supposed to, not like I imagined it would. I was afraid to nudge the outcome again one way or the other. I did not want to put my thumb on the scale. I could think of too many ways my testimony might just make things worse. This was none of my business when I went to Baja, and it wasn't my business now. Only now, I knew it.
这一切并没有像预期的那样发展，不像我想象的那样。我害怕再次干预结果。我不想把我的大拇指放在天平上。我能想到太多方式，我的证词只会让事情变糟。我去下加州时这不是我的事，现在也不是我的事。只是现在，我知道了。
James Spring in San Diego. Richard Carelli eventually pled guilty to involuntary manslaughter and Michelle Pinkerton to child abduction and violating her probation. Today's show is a rerun, and in the years since James Spring's 40th birthday, dozens of people who heard about what happened have contacted James, asking him to find their missing loved ones.
圣地亚哥的詹姆斯·斯普林。理查德·卡雷利最终承认了过失杀人罪，米歇尔·平克顿承认了绑架儿童并违反缓刑条例。今天的节目是重播，在詹姆斯·斯普林40岁生日后的几年里，几十个听说此事的人联系了詹姆斯，要求他寻找他们失踪的爱人。
He's decided help out in a bunch of these cases. There's the paranoid schizophrenic in the Sierra Juarez, the guy who's been missing for 35 years, a surfer that disappeared in Baja, California, the guy in Oaxaca, who he got to confess to a murder and reveal the location of the body. His current case is tracking down three men who were kidnapped in the Mexican city of Veracruz. He says his wife is not crazy about any of this.
他决定在其中一些案件中提供帮助。有在华雷斯山脉患有偏执型精神分裂症的人、失踪了35年的人、在下加利福尼亚失踪的冲浪者，还有在瓦哈卡的一个他让其交代杀人事实并揭露尸体位置的人。他目前的案件是寻找在墨西哥韦拉克鲁斯市被绑架的三名男子。他说他妻子对这些都不太高兴。
Coming up, the Devil's Advocate, a Devil's Advocate that is so disturbed by the evidence in front of him that he has no choice but to come out on the side of the angels. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，“魔鬼的代言人”。一位魔鬼的代言人因眼前的证据感到不安，别无选择，只能站在天使一边。一会儿见，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "Save the Day," stories of people who get the impulse to step in where others turn their backs and do good and rescue the needy. We have arrived at Act 2 of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“拯救危局”，讲述那些人们在别人退缩时挺身而出，做善事并营救弱者的故事。现在进入我们节目的第二幕。
Act 2, I'd Like to Spank the Academy. Every year since 1998, the University of Montevallo, a small liberal arts college outside of Birmingham, Alabama, has held an event called The Life Raft Debate. It's got a simple premise. There's been a global catastrophe, nuclear war, something has wiped out the world, except, miraculously, the hundreds of students who are in the audience of The Life Raft Debate.
第二幕，“我想给学院拍一巴掌”。自1998年以来，阿拉巴马州伯明翰郊外的一所小型文理学院——蒙特瓦洛大学，每年都会举办一场名为“救生筏辩论”的活动。前提很简单：发生了一场全球大灾难，核战争，除奇迹般躲在救生筏辩论观众席里的数百名学生外，世界已被毁灭。
The students are on a life raft. It's only got one spot left. And six professors and other university staffers sit up on the stage and make the case, one by one, that their department, their academic discipline, is the one that deserves that one empty seat, that deserves to be saved, that their academic discipline will help the students survive, will make the students' lives so much more meaningful.
学生们都在救生筏上，只剩下一个空位。六位教授和其他大学教职员工站在台上，一一陈述他们的院系、学术学科为什么配得上那个空位，为什么值得被拯救，他们的学科能如何帮助学生生存，能如何让学生的生活更有意义。
Different professors take part in this every year. There are different winners every year. Nancy Updike heard about the event from a listener, a student back when we first broadcast today's show named Carrie Matthews. Hello, Carrie Matthews. And Nancy looked into this.
每年都有不同的教授参加，每年也有不同的获胜者。南希·厄普戴克从一位听众那里听说了这个活动，那是我们第一次播出今天的节目时的一位学生，名叫凯莉·马修斯。你好，凯莉·马修斯。南希调查了这件事。
The man who started The Life Raft Debate, a philosophy professor at the University of Montevallo named Michael Patton, warned me when he sent a bunch of DVDs of the event that there had been a sort of convergence of silliness at the 2007 debate. And I was looking forward to the silliness as a corrective to what I figured would be a pretty intense overall intellectualism and dryness. Because what else is there to think when someone says, hey, I've got a DVD of university professors arguing about how their area of study is better than anyone else's area of study?
救生筏辩论的发起人、蒙特瓦洛大学的哲学教授迈克尔·帕顿，在给我寄来一堆活动DVD时警告说，2007年的辩论出现了一种愚蠢的汇合。我本期待着这种愚蠢能纠正我所认为的极其强烈的整体知识分子气息和枯燥感。因为当有人说“嘿，我有一张大学教授们争论谁的学科比别人更好”的DVD时，还能有什么别的想法呢？
So I popped the 2007 DVD in. And instead of a debate, I watched gimmicks pile up, one after another.
所以我放进2007年的DVD。结果我看到的不是辩论，而是噱头一个接一个堆砌起来。
[MUSIC - THE WHO - "BABA O'RILEY"]
（音乐 - The Who - "Baba O'Riley"）
The dean of the business school rolled into the gym where the event was being held on a Harley--
商学院院长骑着哈雷摩托车驶入活动举办的体育馆——
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
--to the tune of the song that's not named "Teenage Wasteland," but that we all know as "Teenage Wasteland." He parked, took off his leather jacket, and strolled up to sit next to the other people on stage. He was the first to make his five-minute pitch to the audience.
——背景音乐是那首虽不叫“Teenage Wasteland”但大家都这么称呼的歌。他停车，脱下皮夹克，踱步坐到台上其他人身边。他是第一个向观众进行五分钟陈述的人。
Thank you very much. Thank you very much indeed. I'm here tonight to talk to you about strategy. I'm a strategist, so you'll understand what that means. I was trained to take the strengths and weaknesses that you may possess, and to put them together with opportunities. Now, on the life raft, you're going to need this, because there's going to be some women, there's going to be some men, and we need to put together your strengths and your weaknesses. I know I sound like Elvis, but I'm sorry. It just comes out that way.
“非常感谢，非常感谢。我今晚来这里是跟你们谈战略。我是个战略家，所以你们会明白那意味着什么。我受过训练，能利用你们可能拥有的优势和劣势，并将它们与机会结合起来。在救生筏上，你们会需要这个，因为会有一些女人，会有一些男人，我们需要整合你们的强弱。我知道我听起来像猫王，但我很抱歉，它就这么出来了。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Dean of the business school. He went on to say that strategy would not be enough on the life raft. He also promised leadership. He did a demonstration, asking the audience to stand.
商学院院长。他继续说，在救生筏上光有战略是不够的。他还承诺提供领导力。他做了一个示范，要求观众站起来。
OK, guys. This is your part.
“好了，伙计们，这是你们的部分。”
[STOMPING]
（跺脚声）
Do it with me now. Here we go.
“现在跟着我做，开始。”
[STOMPING]
（跺脚声）
Hey, hey, we got some leadership. Yeah, ladies, you get it. You do the other part.
“嘿，嘿，我们有了领导力。是的，女士们，你们懂的，你们做另一部分。”
[STOMP, STOMP, CLAP, REPEATING]
（跺脚、跺脚、鼓掌，循环）
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
We will, we will rock you. Oh, we will, we will--
“我们要，我们要震撼你。噢，我们要，我们要——”
(ALL) Rock you!
（所有人）“震撼你！”
And we will, we will--
“我们要，我们要——”
Keep in mind that the stage is set up with a lectern, microphones, tables with professors seated at them facing the audience, just like some earnest think-tank-sponsored political discussion or like a college debate. A professor of education showed up on stage in a formal academic robe and then took it off to reveal a superhero costume to audience cheers.
请记住，舞台上设有讲台、麦克风、面对观众的桌子，就和某些严肃的智库赞助的政治讨论或大学辩论一样。一位教育学教授穿着正式的学术长袍上台，然后脱下它露出了英雄服装，引来观众欢呼。
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
He was Captain Education. To his right was an art history professor, who argued that the post-apocalyptic world would be bleak without images, and the survivors would need an art historian to get the most out of any images they created. Her conclusion, out of the blue--
他是“教育队长”。他右边是一位艺术史教授，她认为灾难后的世界如果没有图像会很凄凉，幸存者需要一位艺术史学家来最大限度地利用他们创作的任何图像。她的结论出人意料——
We can build a new world, a better world, a world in which women have the power. Remember, it's the men who have got us into this mess.
“我们可以建立一个新世界，一个更美好的世界，一个女性拥有权力的世界。记住，正是男人们让我们陷入了这种困境。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
The chair of the English department tried briefly to argue for the importance of storytelling in human culture, and then used up most of his time reciting a three minute and 15 second poem he made up about a mythical women's football team at the university and its champion kicker, Mighty Mitzi.
英语系主任试图简短地论证讲故事在人类文化中的重要性，然后把大部分时间花在了背诵他即兴创作的一首三分钟十五秒的关于学校神话般的女子足球队及其冠军踢球手“威猛米兹”的诗上。
Mighty Mitzi might get to kick once more. She put it through for three good points. Her foot was sure to score.
“威猛米兹可能还有机会再踢一次。她把球踢进门，得了三分。她的一脚必会得分。”
Watching the debate, I found myself getting strangely mad, like I'd gone to a wrestling match, and all the wrestlers worried that the audience would find wrestling too violent, so they just walked around doing the preening and smack-talking. And as I remember it, pretty much every student getting a liberal arts degree worries at some point that their education might actually be useless.
观看辩论时，我发现自己竟莫名其妙地生气，就像我去看摔跤比赛，结果摔跤手们担心观众会觉得摔跤太暴力，所以他们只是在上面走来走去，炫耀和说垃圾话。我记得，几乎每个拿文科学位的学生在某个时刻都会担心他们的教育或许真的是没用的。
That's what makes The Life Raft Debate a funny idea and a serious one. It's a forum for the students to say to their professors, make us believe in the value of what we're doing here. That cause seemed lost in this debate. And then the Devil's Advocate got up to rescue us all.
这就是“救生筏辩论”之所以既搞笑又严肃的原因。这是学生对教授说“让我们相信在这里所做之事的价值”的论坛。在这个辩论中，那个事业似乎丢了。然后“魔鬼的代言人”站起来拯救我们大家。
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
Every Life Raft Debate has a Devil's Advocate. He makes the same argument every year. Vote for no one, and he never wins. In this debate, the Devil's Advocate was an untenured English professor named Jon Smith, who, when he heard how the debate was going, threw out most of his prepared notes and spoke of the cuff, making the most impassioned speech of the entire event and one of the most satisfying speeches I've heard in a long time. I'm going to let it play through the end.
每场救生筏辩论都有一个魔鬼的代言人。他每年都做同样的论证：不投给任何人，而且他从不赢。在这场辩论中，魔鬼的代言人是一位没有终身教职的英语教授乔恩·史密斯，当他听到辩论进行到这种地步时，扔掉了大部分准备好的笔记，开始即兴演讲，那是整场活动中最充满激情的演讲，也是我很久以来听过最满足的演讲之一。我让它一直播到最后。
I required my freshmen to come to this, because I thought, because we're covering argument, that they would be exposed to argument.
“我要求我的大一新生来看这个，因为我觉得，既然我们在讨论论证，他们会接触到论证。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Guys, I am so sorry.
“伙计们，我很抱歉。”
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
（笑声和掌声）
What I'd like to do is to give you a little history of The Life Raft Debate and try to explain how we got to the present pass, by way, I guess, of apology. It used to be that The Life Raft Debate-- it's sponsored by the Philosophy Club, and it was a fairly semi-philosophical discussion about which disciplines truly contributed the most to a liberal education. That's what was being contested.
“我想做的是给你们讲讲救生筏辩论的历史，并试着解释我们是如何走到今天这一步的，姑且算作道歉吧。过去救生筏辩论是由哲学俱乐部赞助的，这曾是一个相当半哲学的讨论，争论哪些学科真正对文科教育贡献最大。那才是争论的重点。”
I haven't been here the whole 10 years they've been doing it. But I've been here five, and I can dimly remember when Michael Patton won. He was funny, but he also made a case. He made a serious argument. Steve Parker, the next year, won. He made a good argument, which is a double achievement, because sociology is not a real discipline.
“我没参加他们举办的全部十年，但我来了五年，我还隐约记得迈克尔·帕顿赢的时候。他很幽默，但他确实有论据，他进行了严肃的辩论。史蒂夫·帕克次年赢了，他提出了很好的论点，这可是双重成就，因为社会学根本不是一门真正的学科。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
But something went terribly awry in about 2004. And I can remember this, because I was on the stage. Wilson Fallin stood on a chair and declared that God is a historian.
“但在2004年左右，事情变得非常不对劲。我记得很清楚，因为我当时在台上。威尔逊·法林站在椅子上宣称上帝是一位历史学家。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And the audience ate it up and voted for him. They weren't really voting for Wilson Fallin, the scholar or the historian. I'm sure he's both those things, but they were voting for Wilson Fallin, the Baptist preacher. The next year, you voted for a cook.
“观众吃这一套，投给了他。他们投的不是威尔逊·法林，那位学者或历史学家——我相信他两者都是——他们投的是威尔逊·法林，那位浸信会牧师。第二年，你们投给了一位厨师。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
And I thought it couldn't get any worse, and the year after that, you voted for an administrator.
“我以为不会更糟了，而在那之后的一年，你们投给了一位行政人员。”
[SIGHS]
（叹气）
You've brought yourself to this.
“这是你们自找的。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Because seriously, these are smart people up here. They have stooped to some of the stupidest crap to make you laugh. And all of us who are serious teachers sometimes can fall into that trap. We want to be funny. We want to be entertaining. And we get this sense that, if they're laughing, we must be teaching. It isn't always true.
“因为说真的，这些人都是聪明人，他们竟然卑躬屈膝到用最愚蠢的垃圾来逗你们发笑。我们这些严肃的老师有时也会陷入这种陷阱。我们想变得有趣，想变得好玩。我们产生了一种错觉，觉得如果他们在笑，我们一定是在教书。这并不总是真的。”
I think there's a general argumentative fallacy that's gone on with every single one of these poor people up here, and I don't know how they got sucked into it, but it's probably your fault. It's what I call the Sherry Ford fallacy. Sherry, are you here tonight? OK. You may remember this from the 2004 debate. It's always stuck in my mind.
“我认为台上这些可怜的人每一个人都犯了一个普遍的论证谬误，我不知道他们是怎么陷入其中的，但这很可能是你们的错。这就是我所说的‘谢丽·福特谬误’。谢丽，你今晚在吗？好吧。你们可能还记得2004年的辩论，它一直留在我脑海里。”
Sherry argued that, because you need to communicate to have sex, you need a communications professor to have sex. I'm pretty sure you don't.
“谢丽辩称，因为你需要沟通来做爱，所以你需要一位传播学教授来做爱。我敢肯定你不需要。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
Images are great, but we haven't yet heard the case made, how much do you need an art historian to have images? You're probably going to have images anyway. Education is wonderful, but people were doing education for a couple of thousand years before someone got the idea of having education professors.
“图像很棒，但我们还没听到有人辩论说，你需要一位艺术史学家来产生图像。你大概无论如何都会有图像。教育很棒，但在有人想到教育学教授之前，人们已经进行了几千年的教育。”
People have been telling stories for a long time before there were departments of English and foreign languages and so forth. And I hate to do that, because that's my own discipline that I have to shoot down. But good lord, the guy recited a poem. That's not an argument.
“在有英语系和外语系等等之前，人们讲故事已经很久了。我不喜欢这样做，因为那是我自己必须打压的学科。但天哪，那个家伙背了一首诗，那根本不是论证。”
Look, folks, it's gone too far. You may have been entertained for the last half hour or so, 45 minutes, whatever. But I don't think you were intellectually challenged. I don't think a strong case was made for anybody's discipline. And I honestly think The Life Raft Debate has gotten kind of far away from what it initially used to be and what it should be.
“伙计们，这太过分了。过去半小时左右，45分钟，随便吧，你们或许被娱乐了。但我认为你们并没有受到智力上的挑战。我认为没有人为自己的学科提出有力的论据。我真心认为救生筏辩论已经走得离最初的样子、离它应该有的样子太远了。”
You have a chance tonight to change that. To vote for no one is not to say, oh, I don't like any of them, or they're not all funny, or they're not charming, or whatever. It's just to say, come on, treat us like adults. Argue for your discipline. You can do that and be funny. But please, you can send that message, and I hope tonight you will.
“你们今晚有机会改变这一点。不投票给任何人并不是说‘噢，我不喜欢他们中的任何一个’，或者他们不够有趣，或者他们不够迷人什么的。这只是在说：得了吧，把我们当成年人对待。为你的学科辩论吧。你可以一边做这个一边有趣。但拜托，你们可以传达那个信息，我希望今晚你们会这么做。”
[CHEERING]
（欢呼声）
Here's what I realized when I felt so thrilled that the students, for the first time ever in The Life Raft Debate, voted for the Devil's Advocate. At some point for me, the whole thing became a metaphor for politics in the US right now-- the non-debates, the pandering, the flimsiness, the endless stagecraft, and all of it swallowing up the serious people along with the vacuous ones.
当我感到如此激动，看到学生们在救生筏辩论历史上第一次投票给魔鬼的代言人时，我意识到了什么。对我来说，这一切在某个时刻成了一种美国政治的隐喻——非辩论、迎合、虚浮、无休止的政治手腕，所有这一切把严肃的人和空洞的人一并吞噬了。
Part of the time, I was seated in the bleachers watching it. And then part of the time, I was off to the side pacing madly.
有一段时间，我坐在看台上观看；还有一段时间，我在侧面疯狂踱步。
Jon Smith, the Devil's Advocate himself, also saw politics in the debate when I got in touch with him after watching.
魔鬼的代言人乔恩·史密斯本人在看到后也从中看到了政治。
There's a degree to which we sort of expect public discourse is going to be just horrifically debased, that you're going to have these god-awful arguments. And there's nothing else except crappy emotional appeals that may or may not actually impact on real issues. So one thing that did feel really good is that the students responded. They said, no, we do care about substance.
“在某种程度上，我们预料到公共话语会变得如此可怕地堕落，预料到会看到这些糟糕透顶的论点。除了那些可能对现实问题根本没影响的垃圾情感诉求外，别无他物。所以感觉非常棒的一点是，学生们做出了回应。他们说：不，我们在乎实质内容。”
Caring about substance doesn't mean we have to surround ourselves with massive bores. But it does mean we have to stiffen our spines and raise our standards, which Jon says he's done with help from role models.
在乎实质内容并不意味着我们必须把自己包围在巨大的无聊中。但这确实意味着我们必须挺直腰杆，提高标准，乔恩说他已经在榜样的帮助下做到了这一点。
People like Simon Cowell, actually, have done wonders for us as teachers.
“西蒙·考威尔这类人，事实上，作为老师，他们简直创造了奇迹。”
Simon Cowell of American Idol.
《美国偶像》的西蒙·考威尔。
Of American Idol, right. As of the '90s, everybody was so frickin' concerned with everybody's self-esteem, that it was very hard to just actually come out and say something that everybody knew was true, but it would have been perceived as being impolite. It became very hard or unusual if you actually said, this is a bad argument, to a student, on a paper.
“《美国偶像》的，没错。90年代时，每个人都如此该死地关注每个人的自尊心，以至于很难直接说出大家都知道是真理的东西，因为那会被视为不礼貌。如果你对学生的论文说‘这是一个糟糕的论点’，这变得非常困难或不寻常。”
And you would think that students who have been brought up being told they're special all the time-- everybody talks about the millennials as the generation that were brought up being told they're special all the time-- would be these fragile narcissists who would collapse at the instant that they got some real criticism. But what I've found is that they're quite robust.
“你本以为那些从小就被告知自己很特别的学生——每个人都说千禧一代是被告知自己很特别的一代——会是那些一受到真正批评就会崩溃的脆弱自恋者。但我发现他们相当坚韧。”
In the years since Jon spoke in 2007, The Life Raft Debate has been more substantive, while still being funny. One year, a history professor told the audience that history shows that in the chaos following a global catastrophe, one person on the life raft, one of you in the audience, he said, would definitely become a dictator. And he, as a historian, would be the ideal advisor to this dictator, to tell them how to be benevolent.
在乔恩2007年发言后的几年里，救生筏辩论变得更充实了，同时也依然有趣。有一年，一位历史教授告诉观众，历史表明，在全球灾难后的混乱中，救生筏上的某个人——观众中的某个人，他说——一定会成为独裁者。而他作为历史学家，将是这个独裁者的理想顾问，告诉他们如何变得仁慈。
A mathematics professor, all in camouflage gear, calmly argued that without mathematics, the life raft survivors would have trouble navigating anywhere and building anything durable once they got there. He also promised that no one on the life raft would have to do math ever again. He won.
一位全身穿着迷彩装备的数学教授平静地辩称，没有数学，救生筏幸存者在到达后将无法导航，也无法建造任何持久的东西。他还承诺救生筏上没人再需要做数学题了。他赢了。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. In the years since her interview with Jon Smith, he switched schools from Montevallo and teaches elsewhere.
南希·厄普戴克是我们节目的制片人之一。在乔恩·史密斯的采访后几年里，他从蒙特瓦洛学校转到别处任教了。
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Sarah Koenig, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Our music consultant for today's show, Jessica Hopper. Our technical director is Matt Tierney, production help from Anna Martin, mixing help today from Jared Floyd. Special thanks today to Liz Armstrong, Mary [? Wattenberg, ?] [INAUDIBLE], Starlee Kine, and Curtis Gilbert.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩和我本人制作，参与者有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、莎拉·柯尼格、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普戴克。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼，Anna Martin提供制作帮助，Jared Floyd协助混音。特别感谢丽兹·阿姆斯特朗、玛丽·瓦滕伯格、（听不清）、斯塔莉·基恩和柯蒂斯·吉尔伯特。
Luke Davies, who told this story at the beginning of our show, writes poetry and novels and makes films and TV. His newest film, Beautiful Boy, opens at the Toronto Film Festival this week. Our website, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 shows for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org.
在节目开头讲故事的卢克·戴维斯，他是写诗、写小说、拍电影和电视的。他的新片《美丽男孩》本周在多伦多电影节上映。我们的网站，你可以在那里免费收听我们超过600期的节目存档，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. We were hanging out at the beach just at the end of summer. And I told him, Torey, sunscreen, sunscreen! But he didn't listen.
《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交换中心发行。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。夏天快结束时我们在海滩闲逛。我对他说：“托瑞，防晒霜，防晒霜！”但他没听。
His skin took three months to gradually, gradually return back to its color.
他的皮肤花了三个月才一点点、一点点地恢复原本的颜色。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。